willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung heute
geht es um das gut und böse bei thomas
von aquin und bei leibnitz wir werden
sehen dass diese theorien auch anknüpfen
an theorien die wir schon kennen gelernt
hatten unter anderem bei putin ich mache
dann immer verweise auch in das video
rein thomas von aquin ist vielleicht
eine der wichtigsten philosophen des
mittelalters und hier gibt es einige
darstellungen von ihm und er hat unter
anderem die summer theologie geschrieben
also die summe dass das deutsche wort
summe ist hier enthalten oder anders
gesagt das deutsche wort kommt her als
eine ein kompendium also eine eine ganz
große anzahl von lehrsätzen die darin
enthalten sind und aus dieser ausgabe
hier habe ich jetzt hier einige zitate
genommen ich habe auch ein paar
leitfragen wodurch ist nach thomas
pohlack wieder eine andere gut
genauso kann man sich den fragen wodurch
ist nach thomas von aquin eine handlung
schlecht bzw böse wie verhalten sich gut
und böse nach thomas von aquin
das ist auch eine ganz spannende frage
die ja auch unser generelles
seminarthema betrifft jetzt möchte ich
im tal zentrale zitat bringen die sind
länger die möchte ich dann auch vorlesen
und
kommentare dazu bringen generell muss
man sagen wenn man sich diese
textstellen anschaut von thomas von
aquin aber auch von anderen philosophen
aus dem mittelalter dass die eine
ganzheitliche form aufweisen es gibt
artikel
und dann gibt es immer wieder pro und
kontra argumente und irgendwann versucht
man so eine lösung zu finden das wird
die schulers tische methode genannt
scholastic ist eine methode der
philosophischen und theologischen
diskussion wahrheitsfindung
die im mittelalter sehr prominent war
und sie wurde dann später kritisiert als
nur
zu schematisch es ist ein schema man
kann darüber streiten die man es zu
bewerten hat dieses schema des
autojahres argumentation struktur hat
auch logische struktur aktive hierbei
thomas von der queen ihm erkundigt
gelegt und jetzt hat er den den ersten
artikel mit der frage also fragen
spielen auch immer eine große rolle bei
plastischen disputation ist jede
menschliche handlung gut oder gibt es
auch schlechte hat ja dann würden wir
doch eigentlich sagen natürlich gibt es
schlecht der anderen ist doch klar aber
jetzt kommt hier eine argument es
scheint zumindest dass jede menschliche
handlung gut ist und keine schlecht sagt
doch dionysius das zitat das schlechte
nur kraft des guten tätig ist also der
solistischen philosophierten auch immer
wieder gerne bezug genommen auf
bezugspunkte der tradition auf
autoritäten
theologische autoritäten nun geschieht
aber kraft des guten als solches nichts
schlechtes also ist keine handlung
schlecht außerdem jedes ende ist nur
insofern tätig als es wirklich ist
nichts jedoch ist schlecht insofern es
wirklich ist so nur insofern eine
möglichkeit ihrer verwirklichung beraubt
ist beraubt sehen sich dann ist die
stories die beraubung das finden wir bei
proteinen danach ich dann oben rechts
auch ein link zu diesem video ein
insofern aber die möglichkeit durch ihre
verwirklichung von endet wird ist sie
gut wir sind der metaphysik des totals
heißt es ist also nichts tätig und
sofern es schlecht sind ausschließlich
und findest gut ist jede tätigkeit ist
also gut und kann schlecht außerdem das
schlechte kann nur beiläufig ursache
sein wie aus die jusos ersichtlich wird
zu jeder tätigkeit gehört aber eine
eigentümliche wirkung also ist keine
tätigkeit schlecht wie mir ist jede gut
das ist jetzt ein interessantes argument
dass er zumindest diskutiert er vertritt
diese these nicht aber diskutiert sie
weil sie irgendwie auf der hand zu
liegen scheint das gute ist immer ganz
wenige nachdem wir streben können das
gute ist ganz wenige weshalb wir tätig
sind das gute gibt uns die motivation
für eine handlung das betrifft auch das
thema moralische unter nationen
wie kann dann überhaupt das böse ein
handlungs grund sein das böse könnte
doch gar kein objekt sein was wir
anstreben
und jetzt geht er zumindest in dieser
these die er nicht unbedingt vertreten
muss dir diskutiert so weiter sagen das
böse ist gar keine tätigkeit weil es ja
keinen zweck verfolgen kann das böse ist
ja nichts was bezweckt strukturiert ist
die zwecke bekommen wir nur von dem
guten jahr wie kanadas zu stehen ist das
böse sind etwas böse handlungen gar
keine handlung streng genommen so nur
irgendwelche unfälle das ist eine
wichtige frage die uns auch später noch
begleiten wird und immer wieder virulent
werden wird wenn es um die frage nach
gut und böse geht
dagegen steht und hier sieht man jetzt
wieder es scheint dagegen steht dass es
die schulische methode was der herr sagt
jeder der schlecht handelt hast das
licht es gibt also auch einen schlechte
handeln dass menschen hier wird jetzt
jeden bezug genommen auf die bibel auf
bibelzitat herren das sind auch
autorität antwort dann muss das gut und
schlecht behandlungen auf dieselbe weise
reden über die reden wie über gut und
schlecht bei dingen und zwar deswegen
weil jedes ding eine seinem eigenen
seien entsprechende tätigkeit
hervorbringt dingen aber hat ein jedes
sophie gut hält wie es sein hat gut und
seien sind nämlich austauschbar das ist
auch eine wichtige
mittelalterliche diese
wohnung ist das gut und das lateinisch
ist dass seine und austauschbar können
wir tun tun sagt man da einen
lateinischen gut und sein
sind austauschbar wie im ersten teil
schon besagt einzig gott besitzt habe
die ganze fülle seines seins in der
weise der einheiten einfach halt allen
anderen dingen kommt jeweils die ihn in
der weise der verschiedenheit
angemessene fülle des seins zu also
nicht alles was existiert ist auf
dieselbe weise seien hier verweise ich
nochmal auf platon mache ich auch oben
rechts den linken der ja in seinem linie
gleichnis und auch in anderen
gleichnissen doch eine gewisse
hierarchie des seins entwickelt hat
daher kann es kommen dass manche dinge
in einer hinsicht zeigen haben und ihnen
der noch in einer anderen etwas an der
ihn zukommen sind für des seins fehlt
die fülle des menschlichen seins
erfahrung als beispielsweise dass es
eine art ganzes aus seele und leib ist
welches über alle vermögen und mittel
der erkenntnis und er wirklich erfüllt
wenn daher einem menschen davon etwas
fehlt mangelt ihm auch etwas angefühlt
11 wieviel etwas also an sein hat so
viel hat es auch in gut wie von ihm
jedoch etwas an der fülle des seins
mangelt insofern fehlt ihm auch etwas
andere fülle des gut sein und es wird
schlecht gelangt das ist wieder die
präventions- theorie des tablets ist
theorie die wir von produkten kennen so
hat etwa ein blinder mensch das an gut
sein dass erlebt aber das schlechte ist
für ihn dass ihm das augenlicht fehlt
hätte hingegen hätte etwas hingegen
nichts an sand oder gut hat könnte es
wieder gut noch schlecht genannt werden
haben es die klassische privat ions
theorie
weiter sagt er und das ist jetzt auch
wieder ein zentrales zitat da jedoch zur
begriff des guten gerade designs völlige
wird mit einem seil ist wenn ihm etwas
an der angemessenen science viel fehlt
nicht schlechter schlechthin gut sollen
bestimmter hinsicht gut genannt nämlich
insofern es ein sein das ist es kann
gleichwohl schlechthin 11 genannt werden
und nur in bestimmter hinsicht ein nicht
sein dass wie schon im ersten teil
ausgeführt worden erst jetzt konnten sie
das zitat so ist also zu sagen dass jede
handlung so viel an gut heilt besitzt
wie sie an sagen hat so viele aber etwas
an der science für dem land welche einer
menschlichen hand hinzu kommt insofern
insoweit mangelt ihr das brot sein und
sie wird demzufolge schwächt genannt
etwa wenn es ihr an dem durch die
vernunft bestimmten umfang oder im
angemessenen ort wo dann etwas dieser
art lange das heißt eine unvernünftige
handlung an der handlung die nicht auf
ein gutes vernünftiges ziel als auch gut
und vernünftig werden hier gleichgesetzt
ausgerichtet ist ist auch eine schlechte
oder böse handeln das heißt es lange dir
immer sein an einheit als an diesen
idealen prädikaten mangelt es ja
ein schlechtes sagt thomas von aquin
weiter drückt kraft eines mangelhaften
guten das heißt
dass schlechte schlechte handlungen sind
handlungen aber
in ihnen wirkt nicht das schlechte weil
das schlechte kann kein gut
hervorbringen kein ziel vorgeben auf das
behandlungsteam ziehe das kann das
schlichte das böse deswegen muss im
schlechten immer noch das gute
wirken oder handeln aber eben das gut
insofern ist mangelhaft es wieder
punkten wenn es nämlich darin nichts
gutes ein ergeben wäre es kein sein dass
nähern könnte auch nicht mehr wirken das
bewiesen schlechte es eigentlich nichts
zeit und kann insofern auch nicht
motivieren kann kein grund für eine
handlung sagt wenn es aber nicht
mangelhaft wäre wäre es auch kein übel
daher ist dann auch die hervorgebrachte
halt ein bestimmtes mangelhaftes gut
welches nur in bestimmter hinsicht gut
im ganzen jedoch schlecht ist alte er
sagt eine böse handlung eine schlechte
handlung die ist nur unter einem
gewissen gesichtspunkt gut nämlich
insofern sie auf etwas abzielt diese
ziel dieses rein formale ab ziel auf
etwas auch wenn es etwas schlechtes ist
ist das gute aber das schlechte ist
insgesamt liegen dem lange guten ja
kommt der handlung des menschen das gut
bzw schlecht seien aufgrund ihres
objekts zu ja das kann man auch
diskutieren
das scheint sagte dass der handlung gut
bzw schlecht seien nicht aufgrund ihres
objekts zu kommt dass objekte handlung
ist nämlich eine sache in den dingen
aber gibt es kein übel sondern nur wie
augustinus sagt in ihrem gebrauch durch
die sünder den hatten wir auch
kennengelernt augustinus hat gesagt das
böse ist in der menschlichen freiheit im
gebrauch der dinge zu sehen und nicht
mit dir dann mache ich oben rechts auch
die bank ein also vierten mal kommt der
menschen in handlung die gottheit oder
schlechtigkeit nicht auf konten ihres
objekts zu
ja noch drittens außerdem unten das
objekt eines aktiven vermögens verhält
sich zu handeln wie die wirkung zur
ursache das gutsein eine usa hängt aber
nicht von ihrer wirkung ab
umgekehrt
also kommt eine menschenhandel mir gut
bzw
schlecht seien nicht aufgrund ihres
objekts zu wenn jetzt das objekt als
wirkung verstanden das geht als um den
grund dass er nicht um die wirkung einer
rand
gibt es wieder eine gegenthese da beruf
dass ich wieder auf autoritäten
dagegen steht was bei hose ja gesagt
wird zitat sie wurden mir ein gräuel wie
das sie liebt es ab in der der mensch
wird aber wegen der bosheit seines tuns
gott ein gräuel also gründet die bosheit
des tons in den schlechten objekten der
mensch liebt dasselbe gilt für das
center handel antwort das gut sein
beziehungsweise schlecht sind eine
handlung wie auch der übrigen dinge hat
seinen ursprung wie bereits gesagt in
der fülle bzw im mangel an sein das
beste jedoch was das science fülle zu
gehören schein ist dasjenige aus dem
ding die artbestimmung vielleicht es
wird es schon konkrete also das gute das
was einst viele gehört das bestimmt das
ding richtig das objekt richtig wir
haben also ein klares ziel vor augen
kategorisch vernünftig strukturiert
eine spannende frage die er diskutiert
ist eine menschliche handlung aufgrund
ihrer umstände gut oder schlecht das
hatten wir auch diskutiert einer sitzung
des seminars was ist eigentlich gut sind
dass menschen personen sind dass
handlungen sind es willens akte sind das
umstände oder dinge das muss man sich
fragen es scheint dass seine handlung
nicht aufgrund ihrer umstellung gut oder
schlecht ist die um ständig nämlich
stehen um die handlung wie etwas
außerhalb von ihr wie schon ausgeführt
würde das gute und das überlegt aber wie
es in der metaphysik von aristoteles
heißt in den dem daher kommt das gut
oder schlecht sein einer handlung nicht
aufkommen ihre umstände dazu außerdem
gut bzw schlecht zu behandeln sind vor
allem gegenstand der sittenlehre die
umstände scheinen wieder da sie ja eine
art von akzidenzen akzidenzen sind
äußerlichkeiten wesentliche
eigenschaften behandlungen sind
außerhalb des themenbereichs dieser
lehre zu liegen beide tat keine kunst
das betrachtet was die aktie den teil
heißt wie es in der apostolischen
metaphysik heißt also liegt das gut
beziehungsweise schlecht seiner handlung
nicht in den umständen begründet
außerdem aus einem sein denn sein wesen
gemäss zukunft mit ihm nicht als ein
aktie des zugeschrieben gut und schlecht
kommt eine handlung aber ihrem wesen
nach zu weil die handlung ihrer gatten
nach gut oder schlecht sein kann wie
zuvor ausgeführt also kommt es eine
handlung nicht aufgrund ihrer umstände
zu dass sie gut bzw schlecht sind hier
sehen sie wieder die schulers tische
argumentation zu tun ist scheint er dann
gibt es verschiedene argumente und dann
hier unten die konklusion entschluss so
kann also sagt thomas von aquin weiter
bei einer menschlichen handlungen das
gut sein auf vielfache weise betrachtet
werden einmal als generisches in sofern
sie überhaupt eine handlung ist wie viel
sie nämlich vom charakter der handlung
und an sein enthält so viel hat sie auch
an gut sei ja schon gesagt das war
wieder dieser eingangs punkt wo wir uns
gefragt hatten kann eine böse haben und
überhaupt als handlung bezeichnet werden
zweitens als spezifisches gut sein
welche sie aus den angemessen objekt
empfängt das war diese art bestimmung
dass das objekt richtig von der vernunft
bestimmt wird drittens als gut seien
aufgrund der umstände gleichsam als ihre
akzidenzen als auch die können hier noch
eine rolle spielen diese unwesentlichen
umstände viertens aber als guter lauf
gut des zieles gleichsam dem verhältnis
zu grund ist gut science entsprechend
also der grund und das ziel die müssen
sich entsprechen
das ziel darf nicht nur die wirkung sein
als objekt sondern wir müssen mit dem
grund des guten auf betrachten wenn es
um die hand und thomas von aquin
betrachtet also die handlung als ein
möglicher kandidat des guten
ja dann kann man sich jetzt fragen wie
kommt es überhaupt dass wir wohl wir
vielleicht immer das gute wollen doch
manchmal böse oder schlecht handeln und
sagte folgendes das gute im blick worauf
jemand handelt ist nicht immer ein
wirkliches gutes sondern manchmal ein
wirkliches und manchmal ein bloß
scheinbares und im zweiten fall also
wenn es immer nur scheinbaren gutes ist
ergibt sich auch aus dem ziel eine
schlechte handlung das heißt wir
unterlegen eine täuschung oder wird und
selbst das muss jetzt noch offen bleiben
wenn wir böse handeln wir glauben es
habe sich etwas es habe mit dem guten zu
tun wir würden auf das gute abzielen
aber enttäuschenden star an das ist
nicht das kommt ist nur ein mangel an
guten oder vielleicht sogar das
ja nachdem wir hier einen kurzen
einblick in die theorie des bösen bei
thomas von aquin geworfen haben geht's
weiter mit diesem netten herrn wir aus
der barockzeit wie sie an seiner frisur
unschwer erkennen können dass ist
gottfried wilhelm leibniz er hat ein
sehr berühmtes werk geschrieben die
theodizee aus dem jahr 1710 in der
originalen erfassung deutsch übersetzt
versuch von der güte gottes freiheit des
menschen und vom ursprung des bösen ja
und zwar im ersten auf das ctc problem
eingehen was ist das ttc problem
eigentlich gott wird traditionell als
allwissend und allmächtig und almut ich
verstanden das ist eine ganz klassische
definition von gott jetzt ist das
problem dass das die tatsache dass in
der welt böses oder schlecht ist
existiert diesen drei prädikaten
allwissenheit allmächtig haltung aller
güte zu widersprechen scheint wenn gott
existiert wie kann er dann das böse oder
schlechte die krankheiten oder eben
moralische hanken in der welt zu lassen
wenn gott allwissend ist dann müsste er
das gute und schlechte vorhersehen
kann er das denn dann wolle wenn gott
allmächtig ist dann müsste er die macht
haben das böse und schlechte zu
entfernen in gott all gültig ist dann
müsst ihr den willen besitzen das böse
und schlechte zu vermeiden oder zu
heilen ja vielleicht besser sogar zu
vermeiden ist dürfte vielleicht gar
nicht auftreten behauptet ist hätte kein
platz in der welt warum kommt dann
trotzdem das böse in der welt verbinden
wir gleichsam an der existenz gottes
weiter festhalten das ist ein
riesenproblem und dieses problem ist bis
heute noch nicht gelöst damit kann man
sich immer wieder beschäftigen ein ganz
ganz kniffliges
philosophisch-theologischen problem
jetzt haben ein paar leute fragen uns
überlegt erstens wie versucht leibnitz
die existenz des bösen in der welt mit
gottes an mächtigkeit und allwissend zu
vereinen und wie verhält sich nach
lebens kurzen guten böse weitere frauen
worin besteht der unterschied zwischen
dem metaphysischen
physischen und moralischen das ist eine
ganz wichtige unterscheidung die leibniz
in die theorie des bösen einführt
inwiefern kann leibnitz schließlich das
moralisch diese mit der trägheit
vergleich das sagte und da werden wir
gleichen zitat da zu lesen in niefern
ist diese auffassung dass das moralische
bösen eine trägheit darstellt inwiefern
ist diese erfassung problematisch
ja jetzt sagt lebens erst mal folgendes
mit bezug auf die tradition die alten
zum beispiel plant ihn habe ich jetzt
hinzugefügt verlegten die ursache ist
wir müssen in die materie die sie für
unerschlossen und von gott unabhängig
hielt aber wo finden wir die wir alles
sein von gott her leiden die kredite
müssen das heißt ja auch die materie
müsste von gott stadt beantworten man
muss sie in der idealen natur des
geschöpfes aufsuchen soweit diese natur
in den ewigen wahrheiten des göttlichen
verstandes unabhängig von seinem willen
enthalten ist es jetzt ein schwieriges
jahr mit der ideal natur der individuen
wie menschen sie sind ist nicht gemeint
also die geschöpfe dass sie ideal
gewesen sein es sind sie nämlich gerade
nicht ein geschöpf ist als geschöpf
immer endlich und begrenzt aber dass ein
geschäft endlich unbegrenzt ist das ist
eben seine ideale natur damit könnte man
auch sagen seine logische natur ein
geschäft geschöpft ist als geschöpf
immer schon beschränkt das ist seine
ideale natur wenn das geschütz nicht
beschränkt wäre
dann wäre es kein geschöpft dann wäre es
gott das heißt aus dem verhältnis von
gott und geschöpfen dass das geschäft
eben begrenzt sein muss
und das sagte zweitens dass die selbst
in der göttlichen wahrheit im göttlichen
verstande eingeschrieben also gott
selbst folgt dieser logik dass ein
geschöpf endlich ist
um das ist nicht in seinem willen also
leibnitz und das schadet ihr zwischen
göttlichen verstand der die ewige
idealen wahrheiten enthält wie die
endlichkeit der geschöpfe und den willen
unterscheidet er davon und weiter führt
der leibniz aus liegt nämlich integriert
so eine ursprüngliche unvollkommenheit
vor aller sünde weil begrenzung zum
logischen wesen der kreatur also dem
geschäft gehört daher kann sie nicht
alles müsse sich täuschen und andere
fehler begehen als diese ursprüngliche
unvollkommenheit die einfach inbegriff
des geschäfts bewertung liegt die ist
letztendlich einer der gründe warum das
böse in der welt vorkommt und war auch
gott dieses böse nicht ganz aus der welt
schaffen kann weil er ja die geschöpfe
geschaffen hat
und jetzt kommt die zentrale
unterscheidung auf dich in den leitfrage
schon eingegangen bin leibnitz hat man
kann das übel im metaphysischen
physischen und moralischen sinne
auffassen das metaphysische übel besteht
in der einfachen unvollkommenheit das
ist diese ideale natur dieses
begrenztheit des geschäfts das physische
übel im leiden und das moralische in der
sünde obwohl nun das physische und
moralische übel nicht notwendig sind zu
genügt ihren möglichkeit aufgrund der
ewigen wahrheiten als aus der tatsache
dass geschöpfe endlich gewesen sind
folgt das ist prinzipiell das physische
und moralische übergeben muss aber eben
abgeleitet aus dieser ursprünglichen
idealen natur die in gottes verstand ist
und da diese ungeheure region der
wahrheit alle möglichkeiten beschließt
muss es unendlich viele mögliche welten
geben muss das übe in mehrere von ihnen
ein gefüge und muss die beste von allen
welten es enthalten hierdurch ist gott
bestimmt worden das übel zu zulassen
dass eine ganz starke these selbst die
beste aller möglichen welten mögliche
welten sind welten die einfach logisch
nicht widersprüchlich sind logisch
denkbare welt in allen welten und selbst
in der besten aller möglichen welten
muss notwendigerweise das übel also
eines dieser drei übel genau genommen
dass moralischen oder das physische
vorkommen weil es eben in diesen ideal
wahrheiten begründet ist die sich selbst
auf gott halten muss insofern ihr eben
geschöpfe geschaffen hat was das böse
amt gelangen zu will gott keineswegs
dass morales stößen und auch nicht das
physische oder die leiden wenigstens
nicht unbedingt sonst wäre ja nicht
erhöht und darum gibt es keine
unbedingte vorherbestimmung zu verdammen
und das physische über gottes öfteren
als strafe für eine verschuldung des
öftern auch als geeignetes mittel zur
erreichung eines beständigen zieles
nämlich um größere übel zu verhindern
und größere güter herbeizuführen die
strafe dient auch zur besserung und
abstrich schrecken und das übel dient
häufig dazu dass gut stärker
hervortreten zu lassen mitunter
verschafft es auf dem der es erleidet
eine höhere vollkommenheit wie der same
folge kann eine art verderbnis
ausgesetzt wird also alle formen des
bösen haben eine funktion im rahmen der
besten aller möglichen fälle das böse
kommt nicht einfach grundlos vor es hat
seinen sinn da kann man jetzt darüber
diskutieren kann das böse im sinne des
übels wirklich auch als strafe
verstanden werden dass eine riesen
diskussion in der theologie
gott will dass gute ansicht antizipieren
also vorwegnehmend er will das beste
nachfolgend als absicht und er will dass
indifferente und das physische übel
zuweilen als mittel also nicht als
ursprünglichen motivationsgrund aber
will das moralische über nur als
conditio sine qua non also als bedingung
ohne die nicht als notwendige bedingung
oder als hypothetische notwendigkeit der
an die wahl des besten gebunden ist
daher ist der nachfolgende wille gottes
dessen gegenstimme zu ende ist nur ein
zu lassen also die wahl des besten heißt
angesichts der in den ewigen wahrheiten
festgeschriebenen gesetzen durch die
endlichkeit der geschöpfe
muss gott nach leibnitz das beste
gewissermaßen ausrechnen und das beste
ist eben nie das absolut gute das heißt
wie in der selbst in der besten aller
möglichen welten gibt es nicht das
absolut gute gibt es kein leben ohne
leiden ohne physische und moralische
über nein auch dort muss es diese dinge
geben aber gott so leitendes versucht
trotz dieser rahmenbedingungen immer
noch das beste draus zu machen
berühmte que planen jetzt kommt diese
frage nach der trägheit der berühmte
keppler und nach ihm her die card in
seinen briefen haben beide von der
natürlichen trägheit der körper
gesprochen diese trägheit nun kann man
also von ende des bild und als muster
für die ursprünglich die beschränktheit
der geschöpfe betracht dann wird man
sehen dass die beraubung ist er ist
wieder bei platin den formalen gehalt
der unvollkommenheiten und und
zuträglich keiten der substanz und ihre
handlung aus nach und jetzt kommt ein
längeres zitat das möchte ich einfach
mal vorlesen das ist eine eine bildliche
beschreibung dieser trägheit die uns
auskunft über das böse gibt angenommen
die stroh eines flusses trage mehrere
schiffe mit verschiedenen lagen davon
die einen mit holz beladen die anderen
steigen die anderen mehr die anderen
weniger hierbei werden die am meisten
beladenen schiffe langsamer fahren als
die anderen vorausgesetzt dass ihnen
weder wind noch das ruder oder ein
ähnliches mittel hilft nicht eigentlich
die schwere ist die ursache dieser
verzögerung da die schiffe hier abfahrt
fahren und nicht aufsteigen sondern es
ist die gleiche ursache welche die
dichterin das heißt jene weniger porösen
und mit däninnen eigentümlichen stoffe
stärke erfüllten körper schwer machen
der die poren erfüllende stoff kann
diese bewegung nicht erhalten und tritt
nicht in rechnung der stoff selbst also
nike ursprünglich zur trägheit oder zum
mangel an geschwindigkeit da sind die
inertial kraft die die trägheit kraft
die wir aus der physik er verringert sie
nicht durch sich selbst wenn er die
geschwindigkeit schon erhalten hat denn
dann würde er handeln habe eher minder
die wirkung des eindrucks den erhalten
durch seine empfänglichkeit
infolgedessen muss das schiff bei mehr
materie durch dieselbe kraft bewegt
werden soll wenn es beladen ist mit
notwendigkeit langsamer fort auch die
erfahrungen über den stoß der körper
zeigen wenn man sie durch denkt dass man
doppelt so viel kraft anwenden muss um
einen körper ausgleichen stopp von
doppelte größe ein und dieselbe
geschwindigkeit zu teilen was nicht
notwendig wäre wenn die materie sich
gegen ruhe und bewegung absolut
indifferent verhielten wenn sie nicht
jene eben erwähnte trägheit besäße die
ihr eine art widerwillen gegen das
bewegt werden also das böse müssen wir
uns wie eine träge materie vorstellen es
ist nicht die materie die das böse ist
sondern es ist die trägheit der materie
ist ein art wieder billig gegen das
gewählt werden durch das bewegt werden
zu gut
immanuel kant spricht von einem hang zu
müssen das hat eine ganz ähnliche
parallele und auch fichte in seinem
system der sittenlehre spricht auch
davon dass das böse letztendlich mit der
trägheit zu tun hat
vergleichen wir jetzt die kraft die der
strom auf die schiffe ausübt und ihnen
geteilt mit der tätigkeit gottes die
alles positiven den kreaturen erzeugt
und erhält und in vollkommenheit
existenz und kraft gibt vergleichen wir
sagen ich die trägheit der materie wie
der natürlichen unvollkommenheit die
kreaturen und das langsame fahren des
beladenen schiffes mit dem mangel den
wir in den beschaffen erhalten pr
tätigkeit dekorierten andere fit zu
werden wir finden dass es kam etwas
treffenderes gibt als diesen vergleich
die strömung ist die ursache für die
bewegung des schiffes das gute aber
keineswegs für ihre verzögerung das gute
ist nicht der grund des bösen gott ist
die ursache für die vollkommenheit in
der natur und in hand und die kinder
kommen aber die beschränkte rezeptiven
tätig
ist die ursache für die menge auf die
wir bei ihrer tätigkeit straße
so hielten die plattlinger zum beispiel
auch putin sagt augustin und die schüler
sticker zum beispiel thomas quinn mit
recht gut für die ursache der materie
des bösen und etwas positives darstellen
und nicht für die ursache der vorn die
in einer privaten besteht wie man die
strömung für die ursache die materie
aber nicht der form der verzögerung
halten kann das heißt ist die ursache
der geschwindigkeit des schiffes ohne
damit auch die ursache für die grenzen
dieser geschwindigkeit design und ebenso
wenig wie die strömung des flusses
ursache der verlangsamten fahrt des
schiffes ist ist gut ursache sünde
wie die kraft der materie das ist der
geist im fleisch der geist ist willig
aber das fleisch ist schwach
[Musik]
gott so schließt jetzt leiht es gibt der
kreaturen erzeugt dauernd immer nur das
positiv gute und willkommene in ihr da
jede vollkommene gabel vom vater des
lichtes kommen während
unvollkommenheiten menge der handlung
aus der ursprünglichen begrenzung das
war wieder der die konzeption des
geschöpfes stammt die die kreatur durch
die sie beschränken den idealen kunde
einverstanden konnte für anliegen ihrer
existenz enthalten muss erschöpft ist
eben nun mal ein geschöpf gott konnte
ihr nicht alles geben gott konnte die
kreatur des bescheids nicht
unsterblich oder
unbegrenzt machen ohne sie zum gott zu
machen er musste also stufenweise
unterschiede in der vollkommenheit der
dinge und ebenso beschränkungen die
daraus geben gott konnte kein gott
hauser sich schaffen das heißt wenn er
etwas schaffen wollte dann eben nur eine
beschränkte kreatur ja das war es für
die heutige sitzung vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit und unten im youtube
video kann man dann gerne diese sitzung
noch weiter diskutieren